[Music]
let's set the price at 600 for this TV
no put it at 5.99 does that one dollar
make a difference we trick people all
the time with left digit pricing or
Charm pricing that's where people are
disproportionately influenced by the
left digit price that's genius a small
coffee is two dollars and we sell our
large for six don't forget about the
median make it 550. well now the large
looks like a way better deal exactly the
medium is the decoy we want to direct
customers to our preferred pricing
methods not theirs can you put the TV at
the front of the store it's twelve
hundred dollars won't that scare
customers that are walking in this is a
price anchor it gives the illusion that
all the other items in the store are
relatively cheaper and people end up
spending more wow you're kind of evil
I'm teaching you all this so that you
know how retailers trick you I want to
go to Costco but I don't want to pay for
a membership oh just buy a Costco gift
card I just told you I'm not a member no
idiot Costco lets you shop there without
a membership as long as you have a gift
card just buy them on eBay or from
friends oh awesome